c'est étonnant non
[Applaudissements]
mademoiselle
mademoiselle excusez-moi de vous aborder
aussi
cavalièrement mais enfin
on est là tous les deux tout seul sur ce
banc public dans ce grand square des
airs
ça fait quand même un bon moment que
et puis je dis rien du tout alors que
pas normalement quand il y a un homme et
une femme tout seul sur un banc comme ça
dans un jardin public
surtout si quand il arrive la fille est
déjà là toute seule depuis un moment
enfin normalement le type drague la
fille
et moi pas
mais vous m'en voulez pas si je vous
drague pas je peux je peux continuer à
bouquiner non je vous dis ça parce que
draguer ça m'intéresse pas
de toute façon
cache ta libido tu l'auras dans le dos
non mais vous vous faites ce que vous
voulez on est en République
oui non mais justement
draguer il y a quand même pas que ça
dans la vie enfin je sais pas je vois
moi il y a des couches dragues et puis
il y a des couches dragues pas puis là
c'est un couche bouquine voilà je
voulais ça simplement parce que je
voudrais pas que vous m'en vouliez ou
que ou que vous me preniez pour enfin
pour un type pas normal
encore un parano schizophrimaire qui
fait un blocage agoraphobinhibitif
rapport au plan du niveau du square si
c'est tout
alors là non
je suis pas parano
c'est pas inhibé moi je suis pas inhibé
puisque je vous adresse la parole hein
bon et si je vous adresse la parole
c'est simplement parce que parce que je
suis poli et que je tiens à mettre les
choses au point draguer ça m'emmerde
je vous trouve pas spécialement tard
attention non non mais dis donc je
demande rien
c'est pas parce que j'ai mis une jupe
fendue mon balcon est double Juliette un
porte-jarretelles noires et puis un
petit tripoune et fripon on tentait
l'incruster comme ils font maintenant
qu'il faut tout de suite vous imaginez
des trucs malade ben non mais dis donc
j'imagine rien du tout moi non mais oh
eh entendons-nous bien moi j'ai rien
contre vous personnellement seulement
maintenant avec les mœurs d'aujourd'hui
si on vous fout pas tout de suite la
main au cul on passe pour un ouais
ouais enfin en tout cas automatiquement
si vous voulez qu'on fasse pas je sais
pas moi vous pouvez écouter en tout cas
toute façon vous faites ce que vous
voulez et puis avec qui vous voulez et
comme vous voulez
en tout cas vous êtes sûrement mal dans
votre peau
enfin
si vous manquez une vie c'est pas mon
problème
même plus
quoi
je suis pas votre type
on ne me l'a fait pas c'est quand même
nous les femmes qui avons l'intuition
féminine
ou alors si je réponds
et c'est quoi votre bouquin on peut
savoir votre bouquin
non mais ça c'est intéressant c'est un
bouquin fantastique ça s'appelle la
faune hétérosexuelle dans nos régions
c'est un livre sur la vie les animaux
enfin quand même me fait un effort
d'imagination tiens il y a qu'à prendre
l'arbre qui est là le grand arbre qui
est là puis la petite branche verte qui
est là bon alors c'est le printemps bon
alors c'est le printemps bon il y a une
pigeonne qui se pointe elle se pose sur
la branche bon puis alors évidemment
comme c'est le printemps la plus jeune
c'est en toute drôle hein bon là-dessus
il y a un pigeon qui arrive alors
automatiquement l'épisode elle en peut
plus et ça roucoule normal non non
justement ça roule pas forcément parce
que figurez-vous que le pigeon lui il a
peut-être d'autres choses à faire voilà
le pigeon lui il peut réfléchir à des
machins ou alors il est branché sur les
moineaux ou alors si c'est pas moi
gigambers sur l'environnement ou alors
il a un bouquin vachement intéressant
puis l'envie de le lire peinard tout
seul sur son banc 100 personnes pour
l'emmerder voilà mais c'est pas grave
mais c'est pas grave
mais ça me gêne pas du tout que vous
lisiez tout seul sur un banc comme un
imbécile un livre à la con sur les tiens
quand rien dans le pantalon
alors déjà qu'on a pas les salaires
égaux qui nous font de l'électricité
maintenant avec des bombes atomiques
qu'avec 100 francs on n'a rien de plus
de 50
sans compter tous les viols de sac à
main alors si en plus de tout en plus de
tout c'est encore à nous les femmes à
draguer les hommes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]